do you feel like because we're talking
about ordering coffees now I don't know
why but when I have hot coffee there's
like a quote of like how many hot
coffees I feel comfortable having in a
day but as soon as it's hot as soon as
it's iced coffee I'm like oh this is a
different drink now
I don't know why it just feels like a
different drink because I never have
iced coffee unless it's in the summer
and to me it kind of feels like a
smoothie or something I wonder if that's
that's a no from me dog yeah and maybe
drinking this the water droplets from
the ice diluting it making it taste less
coffee to me coffee shouldn't feel
refreshing you know coffee time nice
coffee feels too refreshing yeah a nice
coffee just feels too refreshing it's
kind of like that's how you know okay
okay this is literally the equivalent of
being like I'll drink a whiskey straight
and I can only do so many but when it's
on Ice no no okay because I can go ahead
because because in a similar fashion to
me cocktails don't feel like alcoholic
drinks a lot of the times if a cocktails
like you know you know the ones I'm
talking about I mean the ones that taste
like juice yeah that's right the really
fruity ones yeah so I gotta go for the
Gin tonic yeah I need that kick
I'm drinking and drinking yeah
no because like I I'll drink a cocktail
and I'm like this it was a pleasant it's
like dessert yeah yeah so sweet and like
you can barely taste the alcohol a lot
of the time I'm like this is not only is
this the sugar bad for me yeah the
alcohol is like a double whammy like I'm
getting [__] exactly I'm like I'd
rather just well I mean that's why I
like it yeah yeah that's why like if I
when I can if I'm at a bar and I'm like
you know we're in kind of a juicy fruity
cocktail kind of night all right where
everyone's like drinking all the [__]
times you've never invited me out and
going yeah you gotta go to the shop with
me yeah yeah God I'm feeling like uh
the fruity 2D cocktail yeah
this is a fruity I've never seen seeing
fruity 2D cocktail Joey in my life Joey
no not fruity just like Fruity like
cocktails okay okay I when I can I try
and double shot that [__] because
otherwise I it's just like juice and I
don't feel it it's like if you drink
like the whole night you know where it's
like I don't feel like I drank no I I
okay with horror I still feel like I can
taste the alcohol three percent okay I
really like it yeah it's fruit juice
okay because here's the thing here's
here's how my mind works right there's
like sodas there's like fruit juices and
then there's [__] like beer and wine
right which I do I guess like I like the
taste of beer and wine but that like
portion of like me liking that taste is
different to me liking the taste of
juice and something that's non-alcoholic
when you add a cocktail and stuff when
you add a cocktail into the mix that
doesn't taste alcoholic my mind
registers it as juice right but the
problem is cocktails are normally like
triple or double the price of a beer or
wine yeah and I finish it like way
faster yeah you ever gone to a cocktail
bar and it takes like 10 hours for like
the waiter to make this like really
elaborate cocktail yeah and then you
finish it in like one minute because it
tastes so good every time yeah but
that's but that's like I don't know
cocktails are not supposed to be like
you're not supposed to drink cocktails
in the same way you drink a juice and
the terms like oh yeah I can just get
this whenever I want so I can just
[__] download whenever I want or
however fast I want all right my [__]
are supposed to be like special you know
I think there should be a natural
barrier uh and if I can give this
cocktail like a 10 year old and he'll be
like oh she does I'm like that's a
problem
so you want it to like taste like bare
minimum tastes like alcohol then you
should be there needs to be a an
indication of it that you like at the
moment I cannot taste the alcohol I feel
like I'm something about it is like that
is true yeah I've drank some cocktails
where I'm like if I ordered the
non-alcoholic version of this it would
taste exactly yeah show me the treasure
map because I can't find it like for me
I have a rule if if it takes longer to
make the drink than it does for me to
drink it then that's not a drink I will
like order again in Japan there's so
many bars that do that where you know oh
there's that one bar that I always I was
typical two that I think yeah you've
gone to I don't know if you've gone to
and there's there's guys and they're
wearing like the tuxedos yeah and they
they take literally 15 minutes to make a
cocktail what are they doing basically
and it's like this big and it's so
refreshing because you've been waiting
for so goddamn long for a drink that's
how they get you bro you drink it in
like five goddamn minutes really so I
can have another one
that's how they get you they're like
we'll wait until you're absolutely
parched so that when you order this girl
and you down it you want another one
asked for a glass of water and obviously
because it's a it's like a whiskey Place
normally yeah so they bring out like I
don't know why they bring out like the
tiniest shots of water and like this
like kind of vial it looks like
something you'd get like a like a
medicine and an RPG yeah and it's like
it's like Max like 50 milliliters and
I'm like what am I who what is it who's
this for the mice in the building all
right this is not like a refresh it or
give me [__] what is this a Waterford
that's the one good thing about America
I'll give them credit you always get the
stupidest largest vessel uh of water
it's an incomprehensible amount of water
at every single restaurant or
establishment when you actually it's
never it's never smaller it's never like
a glass it's like prepare for the slump
jug 5 000 800 milliliters of straight
water and ice in your veins yeah like
you can keep a goldfish in there yeah
for sure
um so that's one problem the Japanese uh
bars need to fix it's kind of like we're
looking at it though on like both ends
of the spectrum really it's like Japan
is like way too Little America in my
opinion Europe way too much yeah yeah
Europe gets it right in the middle I
feel yeah anyway the point being is that
cocktails are nice but I don't want to
eat them a lot of the time sorry drink
them eat them I was thinking about a
different point in my head it was like
how like I don't know why but it makes
when I order a cocktail it activates the
same part of my brain that when I eat a
brownie
and then the ice cream's on the side
I'm like did we really need the ice
cream like I feel like I was I felt bad
about ordering the brownie already
because it's so [__] bad for me and
then you just did like a giant [__]
scoop of vanilla on the side and I felt
like I didn't really need it and I I
just it activates the same part of my
head where it's like sugar more yes
please yeah but sometimes you order a
brownie from a restaurant that thing is
like dry it's like drywall like that's
how it's a bad brownie if I gotta rely
on that yeah but that's why they pair it
with the [__] ice cream so I decide
that [__] that's true yeah the the only
place that I actively like ordering
cocktails like this this is the only
place because I just figured out now
that I'm older I've just lost
get the [__] out Connor you want to
juggle woo-woo for 12 points honestly
like two like a jug for 12 quid or
something or like it is
you used to be able to get like two jugs
as well for like 12. but that's the
thing I I allow those because those are
like shitty enough cocktails yeah but
you can taste the alcohol right is it
weird that I want to taste the alcohol
not because I specifically like the
taste of alcohol but if I'm drinking
this drink for the specific purpose of
getting drunk I like my brain to remind
it that you know I am getting drunk at
this point you guys are thinking too
hard to like min max alcohol
I just feel like cocktails are this
weird cheat code area we figured out
yeah yeah and I feel like we're defying
the laws of nature yeah because because
playing God with cocktails it's our
natural warning when we drink something
with alcohol where it's like oh body's
like no no don't drink this yeah but we
do it anyway yeah but I need that
reminder yeah because like for me like
for me it's important like for me when
the only place like with all the
cocktails is like buy a pool side or on
the beach or something when it's like a
nice pina colada because in my mind I'm
just like oh today's a cheat day you
know I I get to I get to order on
vacation I'm on vacation I get to order
dessert at some like lunch time
I don't know if it is if it's a British
thing or if you just like you know
we're on the beach yeah or we are on the
beach right
but yeah like to me like have you guys
been recommended like these like I don't
know sometimes you go on like YouTube
shorts and there's just like this a lot
of cocktail videos yeah the guy who does
like the Russian guys aesthetic looking
cocktails that I've never thought that
ice could just like look so pretty and
now I'm just like oh that ice was frozen
uh that was that's completely clear ice
no bubbles zero buttons that must have
like exactly who you told you know who
I'm talking about in Japan they always
go so hard with that oh yeah ice the ice
game is impeccable yeah it is you'll
hear him going away at it for like 15
minutes to just yeah you know it's going
to be a good cocktail when you order a
cocktail and the first thing the master
does is bring out a giant block of ice
and a huge knife and you're like oh [__]
it's happening